deutschland fällt jetzt auf 31 23 vs sg
zh und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video leute heute mit max und
medialer und waffen nicht wissen
bestimmt leute ich habe vor einiger zeit
auf einem kanal so eine serie haben wer
ist der heißeste youtuber diese scheiße
ist so gescriptet ich will mit den
leuten sprechen die diese website machen
es kann nicht sein die hab ich mir so
eine app gemacht die hsh hat punkto und
die sache ist diese seite gibt's da
nicht mehr verkauft dann müssen wir
nicht beenden und das auch kein problem
denn heute wenn wir selbst entscheiden
wir haben einen plan vorbereitet und
zwar wenn leute selbst ermitteln wir
drei schiedsrichter wäre die heißes
youtuber dann ist wir werden insgesamt
acht ins rennen schicken von den acht
und am ende eine siegerin da stehen ein
paar von euch wenn sie es bestimmt
denken suchen so ein arschloch mega
oberflächlich man direkt die sache dabei
ist sollte ich denke jeder der schon ein
bisschen erfahrung hat so mit anderen
menschen date und so weiß dass so das
äußerliche so der erste eindruck ist
aber dass man genauso mega deutsche
menschen mit einem absoluten müll
charakter kennenlernen sich denken was
ist das für ein scheiß kein bock auf die
oder den andererseits menschen wohl auf
den ersten blick sagt ja okay nicht so
ein typ den unteren cool drauf sind
deswegen leute da hoffe ich dass ihr
auch wisst das ist äußerlich nur ein
teil von der attraktivität eines
menschen ist hier noch mal gesagt hör
dies nicht wissen wollen wir fangen
jetzt an leute wir stellen euch die
partner vor
und die erste paarung des tages ist kann
es schon mal eintragen julia putics
börse six leiter dann shirin böses katja
okay dann soll in luxus kelly untersätze
paarung haben wir melina warst ja nicht
dabei welche jan der gemeinde ist glaub
du bist gemeint du bist heute die
einzige diesem bündnis für den markt die
es schon
können wir ja dann sagen jahre lang mit
der diskussion heute die erste runde
julia boutiques börse six leid aber ich
muss ehrlich sagen ich habe ja gar nicht
so vor augen
ich gehe mal kurz auf der ok ich muss
sagen prinzipiell finde ich ja sogar die
mädchen auch nicht so flüssig skater
direktor jahres stimme einfach da kannst
du auch im prinzip ja bekannt ist okay
ich habe die bilder gesehen ich habe
meine entscheidung getroffen wie sieht
es bei euch auch nicht okay dann sagen
wir auf 31 23
julius waltermann auf meinem an bord
wird
und die hat auch schöne augen die von
julia blutig sein bisschen noch krasser
also dieses blau oder rechtzeitig
bearbeitet
das ist natürlich alles eine sache die
man nie trauen darf heute war jana und
dann kommen zwei erfahrungen die ist
glaube ich auch richtig spannend shirin
versus katja das ist echt schwer
als ich mein äußerlich muss man ehrlich
sagen sind sie beide mittlerweile
ziemlich ähnlich naja ich aber wusste
ich hier noch krasser körper ja aber sie
hatten noch viel krasser den hintern als
erster nicht wirklich aber ich finde als
ich meinen die sind weit auch irgendwie
so ein bisschen die lustige
damit verfolge ich persönlich halt mehr
als katja weil ich noch für die früher
hatte man ziehe mich gerne eigentlich
die hatten ja ich würde sagen dass ich
prinzipiell auch shirin der wird wissen
heißer finde bei katja ist halt nur so
äußerlich heiß und so zu zeigen und soll
jeder kann machen was er will auch auf
youtube zu zeigen möchte klar ist ja
eigener körper kann so machen ich würde
aber sagen
turin der wir das auf jeden fall auch
mehr als die halt äußerlich auf jeden
fall heißt die kommentare thesen bilder
sind lustig gehört hat eigene flughafen
ein bisschen was über das eigene glück
hatten wir drei zwei eins steht okay das
war eindeutig okay dann kommen wir zur
dritten paarung sony loops versus kelly
und jetzt noch angenommen habe mich
selbst sebastian wende hier ein
jana 1,5 muss zurück in den kindergarten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
natürlich meine freundschaft bonus ich
habe schon mit mit sunny und mit kälte
gerät also wo man auf heute als video
heißt das nicht dass man nicht mehr
krass befreundet ist oder so deswegen
kennen die auch persönliche titel mega
gut ich lasse es mal offen bis zu einer
entscheidung
[Musik]
22 kennedy einer der reporter witterung
wird immer schlimmer da kommen wir zum
letzten viertelfinale melina wirst das
ja na klar mach von nummer 1 was ist das
für ein generell mit namen jahner nicht
so gut melina ist ein bisschen weiter
weg der wahrscheinlich dann eher wenn
man jetzt klar der beziehung denken
möchte dabei so was das ist natürlich
eine fernbeziehung sind bei euch von der
art der recht in dem video erinnern und
stehen weil er auch auf mädchen
zumindest auch spaß dieses gerät ist ab
dann auf 31 23
okay da kommen jetzt zum ersten
halbfinale wir haben nix dagegen für ihn
hat die katze zeigt dass jetzt zwei
mädels gegner da die beiden zu haben
jetzt musst du dir den medien ist jetzt
gesichert
die sind halt so unterschiedlich wie
prinzessinnen bilder
okay das hatte ich frage was ihm
persönlich interessant oder hast du ja
so ist offen mädel mit dem du zusammen
die boxen kann von dem stress hast also
die auf der seite oder mehr so auf eine
die keine ahnung halt anders ist falsch
und vor allem die latte getroffen
ok uncharted 3 2 diverse wettbewerbe
juni war bisher immer einstimmig gewinn
ist hat auch schon wie wär's mit dem
flotten 4
das papier war mit jana das wird so sein
aber ich finde ehrlich gesagt gering
david ist eigentlich fast schon ein
bisschen so ein deutsches sexsymbol oder
ich bin jetzt fast so wie sie der
deutsche journalist und in die richtung
zu gehen glaube ich aber dass ich
wahrscheinlich eher sollten richtung
nicht mehr in richtung nächstes
halbfinale kelly gegen li na okay gut
dann würde ich sagen alles genommen was
sind eure argumente super gute
begründung
ob die eltern auf die reise macht
einfach kurz und knackig 123 wo mein
gott wir haben ein finale
es ist ein schippchen gibt dass er
sicher recht körpergröße mich ob sie
dieses jahr das ist ein argument in
meinem kopf habe er die hier zwei katzen
die hatten rund von den haustieren haben
ja also das ist wirklich de ich enthalte
nicht als natürlich deklarierten fällt
jetzt und zwar eigentlich zu schwach zu
mir wenn wir ein ständig sind auf 31 23
für ihn gewinnt wird einfach es sieht
wirklich auch so sich selbst aus dem
gipfel auch so wirkt wie so einfach so
einen sex symbol einer ist aber so was
sagst du zu verteidigen will er wissen
das ist
sechs davon 800 aber gar keine
verteidigung
aber alles dafür dass in diesem video ja
da hat sich schon in luft aufgelöst
mittlerweile deutsche werde noch eine
folge diesmal mit männlichen youtube
haben wollt dann ja na ja mal ganz kurz
die tür zumachen von außen dann wenn
jedoch eine folge haben wir euch
vielleicht diesmal mit männlichen
youtuber dann schreib das gerne in die
kommentare und laster und check in folge
von was das geht ab da wenn die folge
jung bis alt gemacht also alte menschen
reagiert auf neue technologie und junge
auch alte sachen ich zb schreibmaschine
von mega witzig gibt's hier
du sollst du uns ja